the local labor representatives in berry
south want to buy election why do you
not
well you'll remember in the last
parliament when labour mps left the
labour party joined other parties formed
new parties there weren't by-election in
those constituencies and indeed i wasn't
calling for by-elections then but when
you're elected as a member of parliament
it is your name that people put across
against christian wakeford stood in bury
south people put a cross against his
name as they did against my name in
leeds west but look i say bring on a
general election let everybody up and
down this country make a verdict on
boris johnson and the conservative
government do they have the answers to
the future challenges we face as a
country whether on the cost of living
getting our economy growing or learning
to live with covid
or a labor better place now and many
people including christian wakeford in
very south are increasingly turning to
labor for the answers to those questions
um so just to clarify you think that all
of the people
that voted up and down the country
smashing down that red wall in 2019 were
voting for their local mps and not for
boris johnson
look i just said there's precedent here
um when mps um uh make a decision that
the
party that they got elected um
under their banner
when they if they join another party as
many did in the last parliament as you
will remember very well there aren't
by-elections in those circumstances at
the next election people have a a choice
and i said bring on that general
election i'm confident in bury south and
across the country we can win back those
seats as the conservative party's uh
party is mired in scandal and in lies it
is only kia stammer and the labour party
that have the answers to the challenges
we face
if that's the case and you're so
confident why not have a by-election
i'm i'm i'm struggling to hear you a
little bit i'm sure i'll speak up loudly
if that's the case and you're so
confident why not have a by-election
well look there is precedence here in
the last parliament many labour mps that
joined another party uh formed their own
party i didn't call for by-elections
then i'm not uh calling for one then but
you know if the prime minister wants to
call a general election and many people
are sick to the back teeth of this
government
then the people across the country could
have a chance to say whether they are
happy with the hypocrisy from this
government that seems to think that it's
one rule for them and another for
everybody else
yeah even even wakeford himself though
has uh previously um supported a back
bench bill calling for any mp who
switches parties to face um a recall
petition in other words a by-election
well i i have never said that if an mp
uh changes party that they should cause
a by-election i haven't called for that
in the past and i'm not calling it for
um that now i'm really looking forward
to working with christian uh wakeford
he's made the decision like many
conservative voters former conservative
voters are making the decision that the
conservatives and this prime minister
are no longer fit to govern they are
mired in scandal and in lies and on the
big challenges we face which are being
neglected by this government right now
as they try and fight a rearguard action
to save their own skins the big
challenges we face whether it is the
rise in inflation yesterday to the
highest level in 30 years whether it is
uh
the tax rises that are coming down the
line at a time when people are facing a
cost of living catastrophe or whether it
is plans to actually get our economy uh
growing and the bank of england are
forecasting by the end of this
parliament growth will be just one
percent a year the government have run
out of ideas uh and many people let me
bring you back to christine wakefield
though if you don't mind because of
course it's the mps that are
representing our views in the palace of
westminster um he tweeted uh last year
this is what he uh was saying um
wakeford in the comments last year
labour no longer represents those
working-class communities thankfully on
this side of the chamber we do
listen he's a bit of a turncoat isn't he
well as kia stammer said yesterday in
the house of commons labour have changed
but so have the conservatives under
kyr's leadership in um less than two
years that he's been leader he's
transformed the party we have always
been a pro-worker party we are a
pro-business party uh too we have the
answers to the challenges that people
face and christian wakeford like many
other people
are looking again looking afresh at the
labour party but also young labour
twitter account
young labour twitter account has tweeted
after all you know the younger our
future are they not they say christian
wakeford mp should not be admitted to
the labour party
the only way that labour will win the
next election which i'm determined to do
the only way that labour will win the
next election is if we can attract
people who in the past voted for the
conservative party and i would say to
people who voted at the conservative
party maybe for the first time in 2019
or maybe they voted conservative now for
a number of years look again at the
labour party under kirsten we are under
fresh leadership we are a pro-worker and
pro-business party we have the ideas for
the future the uh policies to tackle the
cost of living crisis cutting v80 on gas
and electricity bills and expansion of
the warm homes discount and also plans
for growth that i'll be setting out in a
speech in greater manchester today for
innovation for investment for skills and
for trading to make britain the most
successful country uh to to start a
business in to grow a business in and
those are the ideas i think the country
wants to be talking about but because of
this scandal in these lies the
government are now not able to govern in
the national interest well we'll find
out what's going to happen next week we
when apparently somebody called sue gray
or something is going to be bringing
back her report look forward to it thank
you very much indeed rachel reeves thank
you